Omar so how was it for you playing a
role that might have been slightly out
of your comfort zone maybe not yes it
was it was it was it was but it was a
kind of challenge after untouchable to
to take like a kind of challenge to have
a character like that very far for me
with the African accent so it was a more
work but I wanted to do that to prove
myself after the Caesar I was a real
actor so I wanted to have a challenge
and and it was a pleasure to do it with
Eric Andrea because it's a lot kind of
family so I'm really really I have the
confidence with them and I trust them so
to take the challenge it was better to
do it with them and for this story for
this character for these topics it was
the right time for me how does a Samba
CeeCee's journey mirror your own in some
sense you came from France maybe what
ten years ago to be an actor here yeah
and and people are definitely embracing
you but how is your journey very similar
and maybe in some sense not similar it
not similar because somebody came from
from Senegal to France and he lived in
France for 10 years and I was born and
raised in France that's that it's a big
difference we don't know but it's a big
difference for me working on a street
it's easy and natural and for a guy like
Samba it's really difficult and it can
it can leave his house and maybe never
coming back
because if he if he's arrested by by
cops directly back to Senegal so that
that make a big difference and all the
sacrifice sacrifice is somebody Don his
life is more more big than mine and so
that's a different but the similarities
Samba is from Senegal and my parents
come from Senegal and
Samba has a like kind of the value Samba
has I ask mind because of the Senegalese
culture and yeah I think that's the the
similar thing and maybe the the the way
he tried to make his life better I try
to do the same well in the film to Samba
and also Alice yeah find a lot of
identity from their jobs both there's
different jobs I'm wondering for you as
an actor how do you find your identity
in between projects because I know
that's a very rough time for a lot of
actors yes so where do you find your
self-worth and identity in between
projects between projects is just by
family in my friends my my parents my
brother and sister my wife my kids
that's that's me so I find my my my in
life just being a being a husband father
being a brother and son staying grounded
in things that are outside of Hollywood
oh exactly and I think you said
previously that coming to America you've
been offered roles that you were never
offered in France how are they different
I'm just different because of the type
of movies like x-men or Jurassic world
this kind of type of movie I can I can't
do in France like that to to to have a
character a kind of superhero I can't do
that in France that's that's the type of
that's the type of general I can't do in
France and also the directors I walk
within us they're not they're not
working in France so that's that's the
difference and for me as an actor I
learned a lot with Eric and Olivia that
they're there the first director making
we acting so I have my way to to connect
to a boil in the project it's the
director so so I love meeting directors
so that the directors I met here was
what's good with a good experience for
me make me grow as an actor so on
I hope it will be continued right so
many beautiful things about the film and
it does take you on a ride it shows a
lot of humor and appreciating the little
good parts of life despite Sambas you
know grim future you don't know you
don't know how it turns out yeah for you
again going back to acting and and you
as Omar how do you remain a beat and and
find humor and things even though la I'm
sure is a different world than France in
some ways how do you find those humorous
moments where dancing even though maybe
life is uncertain but in its I was
that's was a that's why I love Samba
because for me somebody's it's a writ
it's the real life it's a movie but it
shows that the real life and for me the
more is a dramatic the more you you ask
you ask you have to to use humor to to
move on and I grew up like that I
started as a comedian because you humor
for me is a wonderful weapon and you
moved the shortest way between two
people when you want to connect with
someone you move the fast way to connect
so I use you more other time it's part
of my personality and it's the same for
Eric and Olivia the directors that's why
we we love working and being together
because we we we have that communication
with humor and and I think when you talk
about the subject like immigration of
the burnout it's easier to talk about it
with a little bit of humor and they used
to say it's the champagne bubbles okay
yeah interesting yeah do you remember
the first time as a child someone saying
to you while you're funny
like what moment was that was were you
using it in a way to turn a situation
around I know I can't remember because
it's a long time ago but I know I know
it's thing I do since you know maybe the
beginning maybe maybe the beginning I
can't remember when the first time
someone say that but
I remember when I met a crowd laughing
and I was probably 12 years old it was
an underclass room and I remember that
feeling I remember that feeling what was
the feeling
oh yeah like it was like you know being
yourself just being yourself if I do way
and just have the feeling to connect
with the with the with people we are all
in the same you know the same in except
you had all the same connection all the
class together we were we were connected
we were connected I have the I love when
when we make people connecting that's
maybe that's why to order today I do
movies and the movie like that because I
want people connect together especially
today in France we I think people need
to connect and meet each other to to
maybe have a better friends how is humor
universal even if people don't speak the
same language how you always find
something there is always there is
always at the end when you can find that
the good joke there's always the body
language sure uh-huh
yeah right or we're making light of a
situation just with bodies yes nice
thank you thank you very much thank you